sucker-punches next big ps4 exclusive is
ghost of Tsushima a samurai action game
inspired by real world events but what
exactly is it here's everything you need
to know about the game so far the title
is a good place to start you are the
ghost in question fighting across the
very real Japanese island of Tsushima
the Mongol Empire invaded the island in
1274 and they succeeded in taking it
over ghosts of Tsushima takes place on
the occupied island with samurai jin
sekai fighting to retake his land from
the Mongols although the game has a
distinct Japanese setting it's worth
pointing out that you can play it in
both Japanese and English from the
recent story trailer it seems Jin's
fight won't always be an honorable one
as one character notes was nothing so
how exactly will you fight in ghosts of
Tsushima Sony's e3 2018 demo gives us a
good idea combat is slick and precise
with gin snapping quickly between
targeted foes to take them down
although jen has been trained as a
samurai he adopts a stealthy approach to
combat the invaders he uses tools like
ropes and arrows to give himself an
advantage over the brutal Mongol
soldiers combat changes based on how
many enemies you're facing in a fight
Tsushima also features a Dueling
component and sucker punch paid a lot of
attention to detail on each character's
sword Jin's weapon is a family heirloom
called the Sakai storm and it features
lightning bolts on its handguard the
same demo shows jen trading blows with
the female samurai Masako with a series
of fast-moving attacks and deflections
this duel is one of the game's side
stories the climax of a schism between
her and Jin sucker punch also draws
attention to the red leaves that fall
around the battle it considers these
swirling leaves a metaphor for the
team's work on the game like many ideas
bouncing around inside someone's head
jumping off the leaf metaphor it's
important to point out that ghosts of
Tsushima isn't all violent it's an
open-world game and the island is full
of natural beauty to take in as you ride
around on horseback as sucker-punch
studio head Chris Zimmerman puts it
quote this isn't a sea of enemies it's
more grounded than that there are times
when you're walking through the woods
and you listen to birds or
spook a deer or you hear a wolf in the
distance and then it pans across the
path and looks at you before it keeps
going that's kind of magical you can
experience that blend of vengeful
violence and natural beauty yourself
when ghosts of Tsushima comes to ps4 on
June 26 the standard edition will run
you sixty dollars us or 55 pounds but
you can also pick up the digital deluxe
edition for 70 bucks or 65 pounds that
includes the hero of Tsushima skin set
charm of Ho Chi Minh's favored one
technique point a ps4 dynamic theme
digital art book and director's
commentary the physical special edition
cost the same price and it includes the
same digital content via a PlayStation
Store voucher plus it comes with the
game in a steelbook case then there's
the collector's edition which will run
you a hundred and seventy dollars in the
u.s. you'll get all the same digital
content and the steelbook case plus a
replica mask sasha mona war banner for a
cheeky wrapping cloth physical art book
and a cloth world map for more
information on any of those editions hit
up GameSpot's pre-order guides for now
this has been everything you need to
know about ghosts of Tsushima so far
[Music]